I am proud to be British don't get me
wrong I'm just not necessarily proud to
admit that I'm proud to be British I do
definitely like to embrace my
Britishness I know I fit a lot of the
characteristics of the British
stereotype I sound a little bit posh
gray rainy weather makes me feel right
at home
I will genuinely say whoopsie-daisy when
I've made a mistake I have an ever so
slight disregard for dental hygiene and
maybe most importantly I love tea it's
kind of scary actually because I love
tea so much that it's become a defining
characteristic of my personality like I
drink it every day it's the reason I had
my first viral video when I was 16 and
now it's in the name of my production
company and yet the reason I love it so
much is because this is the island on
which I happen to be born when my friend
Michael came to visit me from America
I remember offering him a cup of tea
because that's what you do when you have
a guest in your British and he didn't
really get it he said it tasted kind of
like hot
milky leafy water he thought it was a
bit yucky basically and honestly I'm
inclined to agree with him no baby in
the history of Britain has ever popped
out of the womb gagging for a cup of tea
but what we do is we see our parents
drinking it we hear that it's the
British thing to do and so we're slowly
weaned on to it's usually with lots and
lots of sugar at the start until we
learn to love it and thanks to that
process tea is now a part of who I am I
need it to work I need it to
procrastinate from working and thanks to
my slowly formed caffeine dependency if
I don't drink it I get stroppy that I
drink tea because I don't know what else
to do but for some reason I still feel
proud to be a tea drinking British
person now whenever I see a patriotic
American person you know flying the
Stars and Stripes outside their homes
singing the national anthem proclaiming
about how much they love their country
and how it's that best country in the
world it never fails to make me cringe
and I think this is for a couple of
reasons firstly I don't know if I
particularly like the idea of naming any
country's being the best country in the
world unless it can be completely
objective and secondly if we are going
to name any country as being the best
country in the world I'd like to think
we pick one with the humility to not go
on and on about how
great it is so thirdly big American
patriotism makes me feel weird because I
am British because the most patriotic
thing you'll ever hear a British person
say isn't god save the queen
it's would you like a cup of tea or are
we having awful weather at the moment I
never chose to live here and yet for
some reason I can't imagine myself ever
wanting to live anywhere else I never
chose to have an accent that sounds
silly to the rest of the world and yet
for some reason that's not gonna stop me
from using words like cheerio and
poppycock because I know those sound
silly to you and that makes me happy I
guess what I've seen in a lifetime of
living here is the being patriotic about
Britain means not being particularly
patriotic about person loving this
country means admitting to yourself and
reminding the people around you that it
can be a bit rubbish here and being
proud to be British means being slightly
ashamed of that fact and that is what
I've been thinking about this week do
let me know what you think and hopefully
I'll see you next time god save the
queen you've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching Charlie is
so cool like which makes you like cool
thank you
as always for watching you're very sweet
last week I made 3 whole new videos as
part of collab week all of which you can
see here in case you missed them my
personal favorite is the one I wrote
with Tom where we wrote a song I know
you're not really meant to pick
favorites but um I have now so what am I
gonna do it is my favorite that's just
the way it is
enjoy whichever one you pick though
goodbye